You don't need insidious spirits, axe-wielding
psychos, or even vampires to make a movie
scary.
For some films, it's the wild imagery and
emotional and psychological impacts of the
pics that have made audiences shudder for
generations, despite never being labeled as
horror flicks.
Here are some movies that have managed to
strike fear into viewers, no matter the genre
label.
Return to Oz
While The Wizard of Oz boasted some slightly
creepy moments, it was nothing compared to
what craziness Return to Oz had to offer half
a century later.
Whoever decided a horrific depiction of electroshock
therapy, a talking disembodied moose head,
and sending a young Dorothy to an actual asylum
was a totally solid idea must've been friends
with the Scarecrow, because on paper it sounds
pretty brainless.
"What do you think?"
What the film tries to pass off as whimsy
is utterly upsetting, with the creatures of
Oz 2.0 arriving as much more horrifying than
cute.
The creatures of Oz in this pic range from
an unintentionally scary pumpkin-headed sidekick
to the very intentionally scary villain, the
Nome King.
And that's not even getting into the segment
in which we discover that the fun, light-hearted
sidekicks from the original film have been
turned to stone.
Return to Oz isn't a bad movie, though.
The creatures are still excellently designed
and puppeteered, and while the story is twisted,
it does have a lot of heart.
And… a few dozen decapitated heads.
"I believe I'll lock you in the tower for
a few years til your head is ready, and then
I'll take it."
Not terrifying at all.
The Brave Little Toaster
Before Toy Story launched a multimillion dollar
franchise on the concept of inanimate objects
coming to life when humans weren't looking,
there was The Brave Little Toaster.
And if you find yourself wondering why the
former took off while the latter has drifted
into the distant plains of nostalgia, you
should rewatch the movie to remind yourself
that it's a technicolor nightmare of a film
that no child has, nor ever had, any business
watching.
The themes ultimately boil down to a generational
shift in household appliances—one that is,
in retrospect, totally valid.
Technology grows and gets updated, and it's
strange and unsettling that the filmmakers
insisted that a kid going off to college should
feel a sentimental attachment to his toaster.
We all know where that leads, right?
"I love you."
And then when you do get into the nightmarish
imagery, it's a whole new level of inappropriately
scary.
Evil firefighter clowns, panic-induced hallucinations,
anatomically correct computer towers, and
a crushing sequence in which the appliance
gang finds themselves trapped in a junkyard
make for an experience that even adults may
not escape mentally unscathed.
"Did you hear that, boys?
They want to know how to escape!"
Requiem for a Dream
Addiction is a very real horror millions of
people grapple with daily, and perhaps no
film has captured it as poignantly as Darren
Aronofsky's bone-chilling Requiem for a Dream.
Centering on a group of four people, it depicts
the various stages of addiction to drugs,
including amphetamines and heroin.
The film is unflinching in its portrayal of
the beginning stages of addiction, the side
effects that come with it, and the withdrawal
symptoms and fallout from trying and failing
to get clean.
From self-debasement in search of one more
hit, to a full-on arm amputation, there's
a lot to unpack from the results of this disease
and all its iterations.
Aronofsky doesn't sugarcoat a single frame.
Everything feels real; everything hurts.
Every moment of the film is an agony-ridden
reminder of the anguish of addiction.
It might not be a conventional horror film,
but it's scarier than almost any movie about
ghosts or werewolves.
The NeverEnding Story
Fear the Nothing, kids.
The NeverEnding Story has some frightening
imagery—but it stands out as particularly
eerie thanks to the fact that its villain
is a bone-chilling avatar of nihilism.
Young heroes Bastian and Atreyu are trying
to save the land of Fantasia from the Nothing,
a spreading of literal nonexistence.
It's not a monster.
It doesn't have fangs or claws or horrible
powers.
It's just a void spreading across the land.
Everything it touches exists until it suddenly
doesn't.
Then, there's the horrors of depression and
grief, which is rammed into our brains with
one devastating scene involving a horse.
"We don't even care whether or not we care."
These are big concepts for kids to comprehend,
but by sweeping away all of our new fantasy
pals and threatening to destroy the childlike
empress, it's shockingly scary all the same.
Cropsey
Where do urban legends come from?
To find answers, the filmmakers behind the
documentary Cropsey look into the origins
of the titular New York City boogeyman, a
sort of amalgam of archetypes like the escaped
inmate and the scary man living in the woods.
What they find is not a concrete answer as
to whether Cropsey was ever real, but rather
a sprawling investigation into a series of
child kidnappings in the '70s and '80s, with
more questions springing up every time they
find an answer.
The truth, as they find, is not only stranger
than fiction but infinitely more gut-wrenching.
"You've got this guy, going around, picking
off all these kids."
The kidnapper, Andre Rand, was found guilty
of kidnapping two of five missing people attributed
to him, mostly children.
He's currently in prison but was never convicted
of anything more serious, as four of the bodies
were never found.
Cropsey is a tragically poignant look at the
relationship between truth and fiction, and
while he may still be locked up, the phantom
of these horrific crimes still lives on to
this day.
Akira
Katsuhiro Otomo's legendary magnum opus is
lauded for its groundbreaking animation, design,
and depth.
What occasionally gets overlooked is the fact
that it's a very frightening film.
Exploring the fallout of nuclear war and the
aftermath of Tokyo being razed in an atomic
blast, Akira tells the story of bike gangs,
psychic children, and the evils of the military
industrial complex.
The subject matter is scary enough, but what
really comes down to making it grotesquely
terrifying is the visuals.
From a giant oozing teddy bear to a psychic
prodigy's body growing and mutating like microwaved
Play-Doh, Akira is riddled with visual horrors.
The film is a spectacular achievement in animation
and science fiction, but don't sleep on how
scary it is.
Pairing a grim look at humanity's future with
graphic imagery, this movie will shake you
to your core.
Matilda
Why is Matilda a low-key terrifying movie?
Three words: Principal Agatha Trunchbull.
"Your mommy is a TWIT!"
When removed from its villain, it's a fun
little film about a brilliant young girl with
psychic powers navigating a world that doesn't
understand her.
But throw in Principal Trunchbull and you've
got something much darker.
Trunchbull is sadistic, clever, and almost
animalistic in her aggression towards her
students.
She also implicitly murdered the father of
Ms. Honey, Matilda's teacher and the one person
who seems to understand her.
Any time a child protagonist is put up against
an adult villain, there's a certain power
dynamic that makes the relationship inherently
disturbing.
But when viewers are presented with a character
as fundamentally good and pure as Matilda
and a villain as monstrous and borderline
inhuman as Trunchbull, it becomes genuinely
ghastly.
For evidence, look no further than the scene
in which Matilda and Ms. Honey sneak into
Trunchbull's house and almost get caught.
Matilda is a great movie as it is, but the
addition of Agatha Trunchbull not only makes
it better, it makes it scary.
No Country for Old Men
At the pitch-black heart of the Coen brothers'
adaptation of Cormac McCarthy's No Country
for Old Men is Javier Bardem as Anton Chigurh,
a restrained, lurking hulk of a man on a mission
of anarchy and evil.
His performance earned him an Oscar and gave
life to one of the definitive villains of
a generation.
Physically unremarkable save for a truly horrible
haircut, Chigurh trudges unrelentingly through
the streets, a hit man assigned to take the
life of Josh Brolin's Llewelyn Moss.
Despite his uncannily quiet demeanor, Chigurh
is a human wrecking ball, slaughtering and
maiming indiscriminately as he makes his way
to Moss.
He resembles less a human and more a force
of nature.
Bardem's performance is restrained when necessary
but brutal and thunderous when the right moment
comes.
He's the lynchpin of an already stellar film,
a masterpiece of tension and inevitability.
Moss is doomed as soon as Chigurh has his
name—the horror comes in watching him try
to avoid a fate the audience immediately recognizes
as inevitable.
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
Although it's widely regarded as a children's
film, Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
is a movie that cranks the scare factor up
to ten with astoundingly little warning.
At first, it's a fun, inspirational movie
about a boy named Charlie getting the opportunity
to tour a magnificent, magical candy factory.
Sounds fun, right?
Then Charlie goes to the actual factory and
things get weird.
"This is going to be such an exciting day.
I hope you enjoy it.
I think you will."
The next thing you know, candymaker Willy
Wonka is revealing his factory is run by an
army of tiny green-haired men that are weirdly
inhuman.
One minute the kids are all learning about
candy, and the next, one of them is being
turned into a blueberry.
Another is left to nearly drown in a river
of chocolate, and then he takes everyone else
through a tunnel of outright terror before
punishing some more of the kids.
Like showing them a chicken snuff film wasn't
bad enough.
"This is kinda strange."
"Yes, strange, Charlie, but it's fun!"
Pee-Wee's Big Adventure
The original Pee-Wee's Playhouse wasn't exactly
devoid of bizarre imagery to begin with.
"Aaaaargh!
Come in and pull yourself up a chair"
"A Chairy!"
But under the guiding hand of the master of
strange, Tim Burton, Pee-Wee's Big Adventure
became something deeply unsettling.
The film is chock-full of mastermind Paul
Reubens' signature weirdness, and Burton's
direction cranks it up to the highest possible
level.
It's perhaps no more evident anywhere in the
film than in the appearance of Large Marge,
a terrifying ghost trucker who gives Pee-Wee
a ride.
"This!"
"Ahhhh!"
The appeal of Pee-Wee Herman as a character
has always sort of been caught between adults
and children, sometimes skewing heavily in
one direction and then suddenly leaning into
the opposite.
"Milk, milk, lemonade... round the corner
fudge is made."
The movie makes that switch frequently, which
just makes the more surreal Burton bits all
the scarier.
One never quite knows what to expect.
Going Clear: Scientology and the Prison of
Belief
It's easy to joke about the Church of Scientology
thanks to a few pretty choice moments from
famous member Tom Cruise.
"Have you met an SP?"
Going Clear serves as a tremendously important
reminder that the organization is far more
than a punchline—and that it's alleged to
inflict a very real horror on its members
and their loved ones daily.
The filmmakers interview multiple former members
about their time in the organization and what
they saw, and their stories will horrify you.
From cult-like groupthink to demeaning manual
labor, the stories get worse as the film progresses,
with a couple of men who held high positions
in Scientology openly talking about using
physical intimidation on detractors of the
church as well as its members.
But no segment of the film is as chilling
as the one in which a woman recounts the story
of the church effectively kidnapping her newborn
daughter, forcing her to do hard labor, and
what she subsequently went through to break
out of a church facility with her child and
escape.
Going Clear takes an organization many people
are loosely familiar with as a pop culture
reference and recontextualizes it as the masterpiece
of a career con man, its founder, sci-fi author
L. Ron Hubbard.
That his group has proven so successful even
decades after his passing, and that nobody
seems to be capable of stopping them, may
be as frightening as any sci-fi novel.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!